hello look up do you want sternal
commentaries the show where we're gonna
talk about the show that well you can't
have just watch it cuz we're doing this
before that show even drops this job
just yes maybe they're jumping from that
to this or did it we're talking about
the conjuring 1 & 2 I'm Spence J Gilbert
that's Joestar that's Dan Merle the
conjuring a burgeoning franchise of
which we only did two of the movies but
this is most people's experience of it
is these two I think not everyone's seen
the none like Joe and not everyone saw
Annabelle like Dan Annabelle's yeah the
Annabelle is is yes the antebellum they
this is the parents franchise from which
all of these others have now spawned I
heard they're doing a Crooked Man
yeah probably would yeah how is that
gonna anyways we don't need to talk
about the babadook talk about the let's
talk about go swimmin in it Dan you
believe in ghosts
I don't believe in ghosts but I'm
terrified of them but you take you don't
want to take any chances hedging my bets
against the belief and it gets yes yes
Joe where do you fall I mean you're from
the south man man man that's why I don't
know man that's why the set them like me
that much oh man that's you got out
leaving stuff probably got spooked out
of there no thanks yeah yeah no goes for
me I feel like there's enough ghost
hunter shows where they would have found
something by now they wouldn't they have
found something by now something yeah
I'm not sure where I fall I hope that
they don't exist because what a horrible
way to spend an afterlife is just
hanging out he's walking around what do
you know awesome is it though it never
looks awesome
Casper it looked awesome chicken Casper
look pretty cool yeah yeah yeah I hope
when we die we return to oblique
nothingness so let's talk about the
Condrey these movies are fine fair
they're good I don't want to calm
standard horror movies but they're kind
of like a mash-up of horror movie genres
it's like a little haunted house a
little exorcism a little portal to Hell
you know that little hit Patrick Wilson
yeah
yeah the first one I like you know how
I'm very touched touch-and-go with
horror movies the first one I enjoyed I
thought was very stylistic and
entertaining the second one even even
and re-watching I was like this is a
long long overstuffed movie like the
second ones like they leave and they
come back and it's like someone's right
yeah I like the first one the second one
is a lot it's weird where they they did
this in both of them as the main
characters basically don't enter the
story until midway through yeah like
they spend an hour setting up the family
and eatle Jean and the haunting and then
it's like oh here comes you know Scooby
in the mystery gang they're all gonna
crack this caper but yeah it's a long
long open yeah but aside from that oh no
that's terrible not terrible no I liked
the first one a lot I get really picky
about seeing my monsters in scary movies
I never like I very rarely ever want to
actually see the thing because I think
what's in your head is scarier yeah and
I think the first one does a pretty good
job with that I think there's like
little moments like the thing on the
Wardrobe that's like okay lady in the
basement okay but other than that I
think they do a good job and then the
second one is like we got money
[Laughter]
okay yeah it totally backfired that the
limitations of the first one I think go
to its credit because they so good yeah
it's a cheap effect right yeah but the
yeah they animated like a couple
different CGI monsters in the second one
that just don't add anything to it yeah
the bigger thing to note I found Crooked
Man not it's just a dude like a
performance-art dude that's like I can
make myself look like stop-motion but it
was there's still too much yeah that's
Kate was actually the creepiest part of
the movie for me yeah the second the
crooked undone is pretty okay pretty
standard standard yeah first shot of the
nun down the hallway that was good
that was so good and then when she just
runs at her with a painting yeah now I'm
out
this movie has an interesting
relationship with I guess Catholicism
because it's like they don't really
meant maybe they mentioned Jesus once
and the whole thing but it's like the
devil's real demons are real God is real
God is real but it's usually only the I
guess it's cuz they're in a haunted
house but you only see the evil part of
its really focusing on the the Imps the
demons that ghosts the hauntings the
exorcisms water yeah one of my favorite
genres of film is magic Catholic stuff
where they get real deep and like in the
name of all the Archangels and their
swords yeah like oh cool the metal part
of Kappa is the heavy metal album cover
version yeah like like they talked about
you know it's like the exes thing Exodus
the Pope has to approve the exorcism and
then Patrick wills is just like they're
like oh by the way the Pope said yes
he's like wow I want to see the rogue
cop with his Commissioner version of
Patrick Wilson and like the Pope like
their lethal weapon and your beads Jesus
is breathing down my neck
do you know who I got a call from this
okay new franchise let's watch the con
Drake let's see what we did there okay
weapon
[Music]
just getting mad at his Pope at the good
riddle the Catholic Church has such a
high burden of proof in this movie very
high pressure of that other horror
franchise starring Patrick Wilson in a
haunted house systems - film was based
on the 100% true ghost stories of Ed and
Lorraine Warren and it's a shame when
her brother settled that lawsuit against
them because they almost had to go to
trial to prove that ghosts were real
that sounds way more fun than Annabelle
yes but Sir this is no about that this
was a deep dive thing that I just kind
of fell into this random corner of the
entertainment news of there's people who
own the rights to the life story of
these ghosts on the Arijit goes hunters
war in the Warrens busters yeah where
they did all these halation my idea and
so yet they they spent their life you
know traveling around fighting ghosts
I don't know they also had like that
kind of Hall of Horrors thing that you
see in the movie with the Haunted doll
and stuff and they can and the two can
learn about that you can but because in
their book which they sold someone has
the rights to they also claim that all
of these things were 100% true events so
Warner Brothers felt that they could
make movies based on true events without
buying the rights yeah setting up a
giant lawsuit that almost went to trial
where Warner Brothers would have to
prove that the partially would have to
prove that these events were based in
reality ie that ghosts exist and that
the Warrens
defeated them god I want that Tropic
Thunder ghost hunter movie
we're like the studio heads breathing
down their neck to find some hard
evidence of the ghost I just it it would
look like the Ghostbusters to trial
right we're yeah they're yelling and
like this stuff's bubbling and the
morons are like hey guys brother
they summon a ghost in the trial that's
like this a good moment yeah we're gonna
conjure spirit now objection your honor
I'll allow it
I wouldn't do that if I were you
sustained yeah anyways that I love it
when a Hollywood bleeds over into
reality like that so uh yeah daddy Mark
Wahlberg stopping 911 okay let's go
wanted to beat the Warrens two of the
least funny Ghostbusters your reign is a
combination of Doctor Strange and Jean
Grey while Edie is also there it's so
small very supportive husband yes
together no tackle the biggest case of
their lives in conjuring one while in
conjuring 2 they will tackle the other
biggest case of their no there's no
screen ever talked about men hit films
that will lay the groundwork for a
growing MCU style shared spooky verse
but instead of aliens in action its
demons in Latin leo and the franchise's
signature touch extremely long sequences
of tension building silently as you
point both of these terms anticipation
form and scare ball Bravo oh is it gonna
happen come on enough of the
anticipation porn
give me scare balls oz that is born out
of a Zeiss famously said many times on
the show or other shows or every show or
just in life it's all the same show I
hate jump scares I hate them hate them
hate them hate them and the reason why
these movies are so as I said
anticipation pointed scare balls is like
there are so many sequences that are
like two minutes long and by the way not
all of them in with jump scares there's
some sequences like there's one of the
first one there's like she hears a noise
and a little girl like slowly looks
under the bed yeah
and then comes back up and you're like
it's gonna be behind her no and then
like she slowly looks on the end of the
bed no it doesn't and then just cuts to
the day scene or like it stresses me out
yes oh my cuz I hate jump scares so much
that like both of these movies have
these like long drawn-out scenes and
these don't even pay off it's like oh
there's a very thin line between comedy
and horror sometimes and like in the
same way that a joke the same joke can
be funny and then not funny and then
funny again if you keep going the same
scene is scary and then not scary and
then it's very again because like oh my
god I'm still waiting for this thing to
happen or like I guess the anti comedy
version of like the joke is that there
is no joke yeah they set it up like it's
gonna be mm scary not nothing happened
there's also like a weird difficult
balance and the first one doesn't really
well there's that with Hormuz is that
balance of do I care about you thus I'm
like scared for you but then the other
end of that is are you an idiot now mmm
Rose like why would you go in there
versus like please don't go in there
movie wasn't that guilty of that no no
there's a few there's a few in the
second one where it's like by the time
like the nuns fingers are coming out of
the wall I want to share this go yeah
we're gonna play this out sustained
oh she's interestingly like they have
all the makings of you know a lot of
times horror movies we'll just start
with five characters just because you
need to kill four people and these all
start with so many children all of whom
make it through traumatized but really
why don't we everyone dies and the whole
thing no no there's not one death in the
con drinks there's a there's a vision of
a death yeah but there's no yeah that's
the weird thing that I don't get is like
all of both families in this have five
kids and you're like oh so like they're
all gonna be separately but it's like
both of them only one of the child is
ever an actual eventually mortal danger
like the other ones are kind of creeped
out but then they're all go away well
that's why it's based in true events
because if you have five kids one was
gonna be a weirdo yeah
yeah youngest of fives gonna be one of
them is the mood of these ghosts you've
got never thought it'd be more to
haunting tales about families with so
many kids you won't keep any ones great
except the dude from office space I'm
gonna need for you Ron Livingston he has
a moral watch as it becomes clear they
bought their homes without doing even
the most basic inspections sickly was
I've been like you know kind of looking
into buying a place like a condo or
something like that there's no way you
buy a home without knowing there's a
cellar underneath have you ever been to
your own home sir how does that happen
that happens all the time and especially
haunted house movies where someone will
buy a house and walk in and it's like
the first time that your family to the
house you know they throw in the line of
like oh I just bought it directly from
OC's from the bank but it's like you
still wouldn't like again reports
there's inspections you would get all
the thing other says faulty electrical
and 17 dead bodies in the basement like
you would find out before you moved in
that would be the best escrow process
though like can we get rid of the
poltergeist really clean the carpets
yeah and then the the demon toy that's
embedded into the wok we could really do
something about that maybe they got a
deal based on like asked no questions
there's zero time for a spec you just
have to pay attention and walk in the
door yeah they did it like Dwight on the
office is like buy this house do it do
it do it buy it buy it now right now
okay okay okay well it's like a like a
crazy shoe carnival type deal where it's
like yeah that's yours yeah you get to
peek your head anyways keep going think
we was selling herself or tossing out
any of the old haunted furniture
my ex-husband bought all the furniture
with
when we moved in and got stuck living
with every haunted house cliche in the
book la air movement Queenie clocks
creepy fog creepy Lakes creepy basements
Riebe cellars only the ball in the crawl
spaces yeah there's a difference between
banham cellars yes yeah creepy
children's toys stories more creepy
children's toys
[Music]
Thanks fine now yeah we'll find out in
the actual history book I think the
really before us at work here was a real
estate company who kept selling employee
works imagine yet the epic demons of
myth and legend cuz these ones are
laying unthreatening and they smell like
tunes we debated torture to death really
stinks whether it's a witch who can be
contained by a bedsheet a nun with the
same weaknesses as Rumpelstiltskin
especially we pause like yeah conjuring
2 is like 2 hours and 15 minutes long
yeah it's very long oh yeah and they
have a three-minute scene for Patrick
Wilson just sings an entire Elvis
Presley song now ostensibly it is to set
up that Lorraine Warren loves her
husband knew that knew that all right
I'm gonna use the Internet's favorite
word
but is there sublet where Patrick Wilson
is cooking his family's have you notice
in both in both contracts he sneaked
moves in and he's like he's like the man
of the house he's repairing the the
plumbing he's fixing the guy's car the
woman's like
so happy okay and he's like charming all
the children he's new dead person and he
becomes their father that's the first
correct use of that word on secondly I
had not thought about that he does he is
new - all of these does he want to take
the children as their own is he yeah
well there's these impotent fathers who
can't protect their family and they're
like they have to bring in Patrick
Wilson he himself is then in the first
step of demonic possession he is in step
one description oppression against
oppression yeah he's oppressing the the
man of masses and then finally he
possesses yeah god I hadn't thought
about that but yeah he is totally or
there's the thing of like because this
was developed
you know often true stories um that like
the guy just insisted like I do a great
Elvis yeah I can fix things around the
house just as he was searching for a
reason for being there because his wife
has all the magic powers does
legitimately have a beautiful singing
voice have you seen him in Phantom of
the Opera he's gonna he has a voice
Raoul and Gerard Butler Fred he is a
fantastic singing voice maybe he's just
like listen I love all this horror stuff
but I am not coming back for conjuring 2
and once I do my gonna song yeah yeah
what if they've done the ub40 version of
can't stop falling in love with you yeah
soft reggae break it's a long see does
like half the song like if you can be
sure that no matter what they're capable
of these beasts will stick to the
conventional 3x structure of most
screenplays 15 they save a cat or kill a
dog deep screenwriter net and thrust so
buckle on for a return to decent horror
after years have found footage Drac that
has an entire hall of spin-offs ready to
go
right my name is zak bagans I wasn't
familiar with this jo you you took me a
few clips and man pawpaws Jesus Christ
these guys we watch a lot of ghost
hunter shows in our household because
they're just fun as hell yeah but these
guys are literally like if redbull and
vape pens became a paranormal like
investigator likes very if I did believe
that ghosts were real I would really
hate these guys does every ghost go yeah
because they just like literally like
walk into these like homes where
horrible things supposedly happened and
they're just like come at me ghosts you
coward you killed yourself you're a
coward you're like Jesus like fight me
fight me ghost it's like I wore my
toughest big boy Chico's oh my god man
yeah they're they're the damn work I
mean while all the ghosts are up in the
attic oh I'm like we're not gonna give
him the satisfaction yeah I don't feel
like appearing today yeah there's a
there's like a weird specific ego that I
think all paranormal investigators have
were I'm the guy that's gonna discover
the ghosts are real yeah like I'm the
guy they're gonna come talk to for
whatever weird reason and when you're
90% gel like that guy is there's just an
extra level of like oh god I hate you so
much
I think it's the natural escalation of
these you know alleged frauds which is
that like you you be you're nice and you
try to be scientific and nothing happens
so then you just go the next person
that's attracted to that is someone
who's like more blustering and looking
for a fight and I'm it only is reminded
me of the TV show escalation from
Finding Bigfoot to hunting big yeah just
like let's see if we can track down
Bigfoot and then they failed so there's
like what skill they have to do the out
size personalities because otherwise
like without the personalities yeah let
me show you every ghost hunting show
ever
you get anything did you hear that hey
guys did you just get a little colder
for 30 minutes that is the it's
literally just people silently sitting
in a house for eight hours Allah during
monitoring and then go like just yeah
okay and then a PA like tipping over as
you can see from this replay footage
there's absolutely no way this rock
could have rolled in format a frame on
its own oh yeah alright that's a fun
diversion
yes let's finish this guy we got it in
there it's horrible story walking down
stairs just that's something we all
immediately notice was the door thing
that the doors up yeah lights burning
out
[Music]
chairs moving around it's funny like
creeks and and all the electrical wiring
a lot of symptoms of goats the same as
just buying a crappy oh that's weird
noises okay lock the doors and I guess
can you go go pull on supernatural
the biggest barrier you can face
analysis he does it visit or cap
[Music]
and doors they go door really good door
if you guys ever need a door devil yeah
here does this last one looks like 30
seconds long this squeaker that door is
like a three-act structure also a lot of
doors I hope are tight a nation really
appreciates a nation I'm callin it a
nation yeah
they need to lead scene safety let's see
if yes Father
come starring maybe American Dora's
story yeah look around yeah
can we do the case of the Haunted fruit
lips bird next just follow your nose you
can't say yeah what's that - can't do it
in there I think I think that's just
like their haunted vacation to Hawaii
again yeah there's there should be a
spin off about just their daughter in
therapy because they have a daughter who
who doesn't really factor in too much
but you know living with those parents
it's gonna get she's she gets haunted
that one time when they go home
federación yeah the third act again both
times the in both those there's a third
act where they go home for a reason that
really does not play that much into the
overall plot of the movie and have to
come back yeah well that's strange I
think that's the the frustrating part /
brilliant part of these two conjuring
movies is I think all of that is spin
off every lately yeah it's one of them
is setting up so much stuff about and
yeah yeah so much stuff setting up
Annabel I think the amount of time we
spend with her set is gonna set up jump
to 2018 conjuring three with her as a
grown up I
yeah all the stuff that's absolutely
true stories does she have that they can
base the movie huh gosh yeah there's
gotta be a couple more yeah maybe she
gonna get up with zak bagans from ghost
adventure it's gonna go full Amityville
you know the first one was based on a
true story and then they just kept
spinning and spinning it's truth is
stranger than fiction except when you're
talking about ghosts and demons just go
nuts exactly crooked man's not real or
is all right that's our time why don't
you come back next week where we will be
also hunting something yes yeah we'll be
hunters yeah so to speak
oh yeah there you go Joe thanks for
watching honest trailer commentaries
we'll be back love you bye
[Music]
you